right
[Music]
good afternoon thank you everyone for
being here this afternoon
i wanted to take some time a few minutes
to provide some updates regarding three
initiatives i spoke about last time i
was here
before i provide those updates i want to
take a moment to share some encouraging
news
nevada administered close to 20 percent
more covet 19 vaccines than the national
average during our last update
let's keep this up vaccinating more
people keeps people safe
nevada was the first state to reinstate
indoor masking in areas of substantial
and high transmission regardless of
vaccination status
we are now seeing a slowing of covid19
growth in our state
in fact nevada has had the second
slowest
19 growth in the nation over the past
two weeks at 15
compared to the national average of 118
we know mass are an effective mitigation
strategy and remain a critical tool to
protect our health care system and slow
the spread while we work to get more
people vaccinated
as you may remember a little more than a
week and a half ago i spoke about three
areas the state is working on to help
manage this pandemic and get shots in
arms
first i asked the medical advisors to
look at vaccination requirements for all
students attending in-person classes at
our public colleges and universities
under
the nevada system of higher education
and she
the mat agreed with the unanimous
recommendation from the nc covet 19 task
force to require vaccinations for
students while originally on the agenda
for september 3rd the board of health
has called an emergency meeting to
discuss this topic at the end of this
week
to all of the higher ed students out
there if you have not yet done so i want
to encourage those who plan to return to
in-person learning to get your covit 19
vaccination before
returning to campus
additionally i asked medical advisors
for vaccination recommendation
regarding those who work with vulnerable
populations
these recommendations will help guide
conversations and actions we can take
moving forward
and we are currently working with
officials and partners to discuss and
determine next steps
we will provide updates to explore
policy options
the final topic topic i discussed in my
last press conference
one i will be discussing in more detail
today
was related to how we make large
gatherings safer in nevada
as we all know nevada is an incredible
location for concerts sporting events
and so much more in fact i would argue
we are the best at those venues
that's great for residents and visitors
but can post challenges during a
pandemic
that's why public health officials have
been working with event operators and
partners to come up with options for
hosting safer large events
the first option
is to continue following the current
mask requirement that states that all
persons in counties with substantial or
high community transmission rates
are required to wear face coverings
while in public indoor spaces regardless
of vaccine status
you have to wear the mask regardless
vaccine status
the sec second option
which becomes effective with this new
directive number 49
provides a masking exception for large
event operators that choose to require
proof of vaccination for all attendees
let me explain
if a large event venue chooses to
require vaccination proof for all
attendees
those that are fully vaccinated will be
allowed to take their masks off
partially vaccinated attendees may still
attend but they must wear their mask at
the event
additionally children who are not
eligible for vaccination due to their
age may attend the event
but must wear a mask
in order to be eligible for this masking
exception for fully vaccinated
individuals at large indoor events
the following requirements must be met
the venue must have fixed seating
capacity of 4 000 people or more
the event must require tickets or
registration and be open only to those
who have tickets or are registered
the event
operator must maintain access control
that effectively prevents unticketed or
unauthorized persons from attending
event operators must implement a method
of verifying vaccination status that is
accurate effective and reliable
staff must be sufficient in number and
adequately trained to implement this
program
and again event operators may choose to
admit attendees who are only partially
vaccinated but those attendees must
continue to wear a mask during the event
event operators must have a system in
place to distinguish attendees who are
fully vaccinated from those who are only
partially vaccinated
and must enforce the mask requirement
for all attendees who are not fully
vaccinated during the event
if someone fails to provide proof of
covet-19 vaccination they must not be
admitted
this gives an option for event
organizers to choose between requiring
masks indoors for all attendees
regardless of vaccination status
or making the choice to only allow
vaccinated individuals into their events
and letting the fully vaccinated take
their masks off
i want to be clear
this is not a requirement to show proof
of vaccination to attend a large event
this is not a mandate
it is an optional exception to the
general master requirement if the event
operator chooses
to require proof of vaccination for all
attendees
we're giving our private sector partners
the choices
and flexibility to lead in this area
and i'm so proud of the many that have
already begun leading
we've seen many nevada event operators
and businesses in the last two weeks
step up and make decisions to increase
vaccination rates and thus the safety of
their employees and their guests
we know that these po for these policies
to be successful it takes public sector
action the private sector and the
general public to work together and to
get it right
my goal with today's new policy choice
is to provide the private sector more
options that come with the reward for
the public the ability to take off their
mass during a concert or game if and
only if they are fully vaccinated
and of course we hope that this helps
get more vaccine nevada's vaccinated
so that we can get out of this pandemic
that's why state health officials stand
ready to work with the event operators
to stand up vaccine
opportunities at these event sites
to give all attendees every chance to
get their shot and attend the event
again at this time
this directive applies to large ticketed
gatherings and venues with fixed seating
over 4 000 or more
and locations where venue and event
operations can effectively control
access to the event to make sure tickets
or registration is adequately verified
as has been the case since the start of
the pandemic a private entity or local
government can always implement stronger
mitigation strategies if they choose
to the smaller venues and businesses out
there who are interested in having this
option available to them
i want to make sure you know that i
share that goal
as we implement this policy for our
largest venues
please know we'll be working to expand
this option to every venue and business
in the state
we will be reaching out to our chambers
of commerce and other partners to make
sure we get this right
as we work to expand the option
the emergency directive and more
guidance will be released later this
evening
thank you for all of you for being here
i want to remind nevadans that it's
easier than ever to get the kovit 19
vaccination
vaccines are free they're safe and
they're effective
visit nvcobitfider.org
find a clinic near you
i would now be happy to take a few
questions
if you're um you can come to the event
or you have to show proof of the
negative test in those cases
what happens when you have both the
groups does that mean that the
vaccinated individuals can take their
masks off and they
non-vaccinated who have the negative
tests let's
keep them on and if that's the case how
do you monitor
no that that isn't what happens here
what this is is if the venue chooses
that everybody will be vaccinated
everybody in the event not a negative
test everybody in the event will have
initiated their vaccine
then this option would be available to
them
who are not eligible
they would be required to maintain
wearing a mask at all times but there
would be an exception for them yes
correct
governor thanks um
for those who
might confuse this if if there's a
distinction between this
and a vaccine passport please address
any differences
this is an option that we're making
available to our businesses
if they choose to go down path a they
can maintain what we have right now the
status quo which is everybody has to
wear a mask at all times inside the
venue
if they choose to go down path b
it requires that everybody be vaccinated
at least they have their initial dose
and if they have initial vote those they
have to wear their mask but if everybody
is vaccinated they can take off their
masks so
not a
vaccine possible no not a vaccine
passport
dana and then i'm sorry i don't know
your name
uh do you really think that a policy
like that could be
adequately
enforced at all
well i i wasn't at the event but i saw
your comments that it wasn't enforced
and i don't know uh this would eliminate
that enforcement
problem if everybody walking in through
the turnstile has to prove that they're
vaccinated
we won't have to have to wear masks
that's what's going to eliminate them
they won't have to have
hundreds of ushers walking around saying
your mask is slipping cover your nose
you don't have a mascot this would give
the event operator
an option they can go down one path and
have to enforce the rules go down path b
and
have people be able to take their mass
off
no
if they choose option b
everyone going into the stadium will
have to have received at least their
first dose
no there would not be that option if the
venue
for example a football game decided they
want to pursue option b
for public safety reasons and for their
own business entrance interest and have
everybody vaccinated and they say that
you have to have initiated your vaccine
either your first one you can get your
first one in the parking lot we're
trying to put up vaccination sites in
their form or you're fully vaccinated
you can do that if you don't have a
vaccine your first vaccine you want to
go the game you can't go
even if you're not fully vaccinated
yeah if no if you're not fully
vaccinated if you get to the game for
example
and you're not vaccinated and i say look
you can go over to that tent and get
your first vaccine and you go over to
that tent you get your first vaccine and
you come back you can now attend the
event with your mascot
but once you've been fully vaccinated
which is two weeks after your second
dose then you don't have to wear the
message
you that will be up to uh the venue
operator will have to come up with a
plan that they can identify the
difference between the two of them now
whether that's through a wristband it's
through some other technology that would
be up to them they'd have to present us
with the plan okay so my original
question is do you think that that kind
of scenario
i do
i do and i think that it's going to
encourage a lot of people to get that
vaccine both the first and the second
dose they're going to say i want to take
my mask off and go the raider game so
they're going to go over and get the
vaccine and two weeks later they might
do it begrudgingly they're going to go
get their second vaccine so that's the
sorry i'm sorry i don't know your name
back here and then we'll come ricky
john donald from ktnv
lambing elementary school in henderson
announced that they're going distance
learning for two weeks because of covet
exposure i mean what level of danger has
to exist to push an entire school to do
something like that and what does that
mean for all schools in the near future
if that kind of thing keeps happening
that uh authority was relegated to the
school districts in the local areas so
uh i'm aware of the situation i just
became aware of this situation late this
afternoon that they had left in
elementary school so confident that the
southern valley health district working
in concert with ccsd will be able to
resolve the situation michelle anderson
thanks governor thanks for the question
just to add a little bit more on to that
uh on to what the governor said um so
within the department of health and
human services um they put out guidance
recently um for the return of in-person
learning that outlines exactly what the
criteria would look like
for a full quarantine
of students at a school and it mirrors a
lot of what is in the cdc
recommendations as
oh mgm well announced that they would
require other workforce to be vaccinated
do you foresee other private businesses
doing this and do you encourage it i
certainly
encourage you and thankful to mgm that
they're doing it that they're requiring
vaccines are the only way out of this we
used to have mass and hand sanitizer and
social distancing now vaccines are way
out of this pandemic so if they're
requiring that for their employees i
think it's absolutely terrific and i
encourage any employer to look at that
option yes
with this directive you've mentioned
raider games tonight have any large
venue operators expressed interest in a
plan like this one in developing the
plan we worked with our you know the
venue partners and with our health
professionals to come up with a plan
we're gonna we laid it out for them
they're gonna be made aware of it just
as you're being made aware of it through
the directive and they're gonna have to
decide for themselves whether it's a
one of our colleges or universities one
of our professional teams or a big
concert operators involved in those
conversations no we didn't have a this
was this was not developed as planned
for one operator or one venue
this was operated to get kind of what
the point dana was making to be
realistic it's tough when you have i
don't care if it's twenty thousand or
sixty five thousand to have ushers or
whomever
saying put your mouth regulating math
score it's very difficult situation and
those employees are abused significantly
at that time so we came up with an
option that would work if the venue
operator chooses to pursue it i don't
know what venue operators if any they're
going to choose to pursue it i hope that
they will because one is going to
really be able to increase our number of
vaccines that we give out and two i
think it'll be a great environment for
people
and then we'll come over here
so if um
if a private venue is in a
small business
we don't want them to be able to take
off
sorry
yeah if a private venue can put any
restrictions they want place if a
restaurant or a
store or whomever says we want every
customer coming in here to be vaccinated
and wear a mask they can still do
zapata from that
how private entities can face the
problem that we're having with a fake
vaccines car in the country well using a
fake or a false
vaccine card is a crime
you know we're going to have to work
with our local law enforcement the
attorney general's office to make sure
this wasn't set up to encourage people
to try to circumvent the law like kids
did when they were
21 or 18 and tried to get a fake id to
get into a
dance club this is done to protect
public health and we're trying to make
accommodate the situation for venues and
hopefully people will take it in the
spirit it's intended but they have a way
to
check that with the
without getting into the details that
they're using for the uh
verification process
you know it's their responsibility to
make sure that people are fully
drew and vaccinated we'll come back over
thank you governor james schaefer with
the las vegas review journal um
for small business owners that get very
concerned whenever there's an update
from your office saying they're
concerned that the next update might
cost them their livelihoods do you speak
to the easing the program
yeah we've done everything we possibly
can to make give first off give people
as much notice as we possibly can about
these things to make it easier for all
businesses small businesses large
businesses
and individual families to succeed and
to be
comfortable and at the same time feel
safe that's what's behind this if you
don't want to do this no small business
has to worry about complying with us
if you do want to take the advantage and
you've got a venue of 4 000 people or
more you can take advantage of it and
we'd like to expand this to more
businesses but this isn't a mandate it's
not a requirement it's not rolling
anything back we're trying to open up
our economy more in getting more people
working and this policy is directed
towards doing just that
governor at this point if say a regular
business one to have a vaccine mandate
could
sure any small business can enact a
vaccine man they don't have to wear it
nope
no we have a mandate in place of small
that businesses indoors have to wear a
mask
this is an exception and it's being done
on a
hopefully experimental successful basis
and we're going to see how this works
i tell you what what i'd like to see is
have absolutely everybody get vaccinated
and everybody get rid of these mess that
would be terrific and i'd be the first
one leading the parade encouraging that
yes there's a possibility that with time
we can expand this and to see how it
works it's a little more difficult for a
small business who doesn't have the
resources or wherewithal to do the
verification that's why we're starting
at this
uh moving level this auction is there
any concern that some large venues might
say you know we might be able to make
more money by just not following this um
and then parts of that question if they
decide not to do this
it's difficult to enforce any
mandate
i think everybody is aware that i'm
certainly aware that we understand that
uh the large venues that are sporting
events or concerts that get people
excited and you know make it more
difficult to enforce these events
i believe in my heart that these
businesses want to keep their employees
and the general public as safe as
possible
now i understand that they want to make
money they're in the business of making
money i get that but they also might
realize to get to your point that they
can sell more tickets if people know
they're going there everybody in that
stadium is vaccinated and they can take
their mask off
that might be an incentive to get people
to buy a ticket as opposed to a obstacle
to buying a ticket and we're hoping
that's the way it works
thank you governor for taking my
question is there a point where
obviously this is an option for those
larger venues is there a point where
you'll make this option a mandatory
requirement is there a
perceived threshold for that yeah no i i
don't want to get into what you know
benchmarks and you know uh
tripping points that you know we'd go to
something different
i am hopeful this is cutting edge
there's no other venues in the country
that are doing this
this is something that we think will
work we're confident it's going to work
i think it's going to keep people safe i
think it is going to get people more
people wanting to go to an event because
they know that when they walk in that
arena or that stadium everybody's
vaccinated now will there be the outlier
who's trying to use a fake card and
trying to circumvent the system
certainly hopefully that's going to be
small and far and few between and
they'll be prosecuted for doing so but
the goal is that it'll be a safer event
a safer venue and if you get to that
football game if you want to go watch
the rebels play football and you get
there and they say that not assuming
they did implement the policy and i
don't know if they will implement the
policy
and the person at the ticket taker says
hey look i'm sorry for you to get in do
you have a vaccine you say no
you're gonna say well i'm sorry you
can't come in and then they say but if
you go over to that tent and you get
your first vaccine you can come on back
you can come in the game
and you have to wear your mask but after
you're fully vaccinated you won't have
to wear your mask
i feel personally it's going to
encourage a lot of people to go over to
that chapter that trailer and get the
vaccine and that's what this is about is
getting more people vaccinated
well i'm doing everything we possibly
can i don't know if we're requiring it
but i encourage a private sector as
brought up previously with mgm
you know they uh require that their
salaried people and all new hires are
vaccinated i hope that more businesses
require their front-end staff and their
back of the house and what not to be
vaccinated it's the best way to keep
everyone safe and to stomp out this
virus and you know we're running against
the clock here in order to do that and
any idea that somebody has that could
get their employees or customers if they
choose to get vaccinated i think that's
great and i encourage them to do that
do you ever have any venues already
alerted you that they'd like to do this
and plan on doing this no they have not
no i don't know what they'll we haven't
put out the directive yet it'll be going
on in a couple hours and they'll have to
decide for themselves whether it's best
or not okay a quick question about
timing image
a few weeks ago we were talking about
the world cup soccer world cup and we
talked about the folks who weren't based
there
raiders game was two days ago so this is
in response to that
i i don't want to say it's in response
to that necessarily but i was aware of
the pictures that
folks mentioned that
i saw those events and talked to the
operators of those venues and
we exchanged
opinions and ideas and this is what we
came up with your opinion
was
what about my opinion is relying on our
health professionals and our scientific
information
that
i'm a realist again i understand that
it's difficult
in a venue of 20 or 65 000 people to
keep people massed up i get that they
get excited somebody scores a touchdown
they start cheering i totally understand
that there's a great song playing they
take off their mass they want to start
singing i get that i totally understand
we're trying to do everything we can
to make sure that they can do that
safely and that's why everybody in that
venue being vaccinated michelle if you
can have anything
no just to iterate and reminder a week
and a half ago when the governor gave
his
press conference is when we laid out
that this is going to be an area that
the governor wanted state public health
officials to look at that included again
large gatherings um so really that was
the precipice for beginning to explore
of course throughout the pandemic we are
always exploring ways to keep people
safe while also striking that balance
between protecting public health and
also our very fragile economy and the
jobs that we've managed to recover
through the governor's leadership
people who are um can also still test
positive is it safe to say hey we can
still take our masks off not knowing if
there's still someone in there who's
vaccinated
there are breakthrough cases you're
absolutely right nobody's denying that
but i think it's also clear that the
number of breakthrough cases are nowhere
near they're a relatively small portion
i want to emphasize that because they
would if an event you chose to take
advantage of this that does not mean
that you can't wear your mask when you
go inside of them if you would feel more
comfortable even though they might be
totally if they say it's a vaccinated
uh venue and everybody got vaccinated if
you as an individual choose to go to
your that game or that constant wear
your mask you're free to do so that's a
choice you can make
thank you